vamos a intentar resolver la siguiente
integral tengo en la integral de 1 entre
la raíz de 1 - x cuadrada todo esto que
multiplica al diferencial de x y bueno
si tú lo intentas ser por sustitución no
vas a pasar mucho tiempo y no creo que
llegues a ningún lado es por esa razón
que quiero empezar a ver un nuevo tema
en esta ocasión también vamos a ver un
tipo de sustitución pero sustitución
trigonométricas es decir nos vamos a
fijar en las funciones trigonométricas y
es que fíjate más o más la lógica sigue
aquí y es que siempre que tengas la raíz
de a menos equis cuadrada que en este
caso a es 1 se nos ocurre usar la
sustitución trigonométricas y las ideas
más o menos así sí sustituyó a x por el
seno de un ángulo me queda uno menos el
seno cuadrado que es el coste no
cuadrado y la raíz del coseno cuadrados
el coseno por lo tanto voy a intentarlo
hacer en esta ocasión voy a hacer el
cambio de variable x igual al seno de
teta y antes de hacer todas las
operaciones lo primero que quiero que
veamos es los dominios si te das cuenta
esta expresión está definida solamente
cuando x está en
1 y menos 1 porque si x vale algo que
sea más grande que menos 11 esto va a
ser negativo y de hecho si x vale 1 o
menos 1 esto me saldría 0 y no podemos
dividir entre 0 por lo tanto el primer
dominio que quiero que veamos es este
siempre es muy importante revisar los
dominios para ver que no estamos
contrayendo demasiado la equis en un
cambio de variable cuyos dominios sean
distintos a los originales
la variable x tiene que ser mayor que
menos 1 y menor que 1 que 1 positivo muy
bien y ojo aquí es mayor y menor
estricto porque si fuera 1 positivo o
negativo el denominador de esta fracción
me quedaría 0 y por lo tanto es dividir
entre 0 no se puede y bueno ahora que ya
sabemos qué valores puede tomar x ahora
hay que pensar qué valores puede tomar
theta o el seno de teta para poder
resolver esta ecuación y para eso lo que
tenemos que hacer es despejar el ángulo
teta y para despejar el ángulo teta hay
que pasar el seno del otro lado de la
ecuación y como vamos a pasar el seno
del otro lado de la ecuación con su
función inversa y la función inversa del
seno
el ángulo cuyo seno es x entonces voy a
decir que teta es igual al ángulo cuyo
seno o al arco cuyo seno es equis y
bueno ya que tenemos la teta por fin
renombrada o definida así entonces lo
que voy a buscar ahora son los valores
que puede tomar teta y para eso voy a
dibujar aquí mi círculo unitario voy a
intentar hacerlo lo mejor posible tengo
los ejes x bien y bueno entonces si yo
quiero que x valera entre este valor y
este valor entonces los valores que
puede tomar el ángulo están definidos en
el primer cuadrante y en el cuarto
cuadrante y nada más por ejemplo si x
vale este valor por lo tanto voy a
buscar un ángulo que esté en el primer
cuadrante como éste no que esté en el
segundo cuadrante importante no estoy
buscando uno que esté en el segundo
cuadrante por ejemplo si x vale entonces
ahora este valor entonces mi ángulo va a
ser este que está en el cuarto cuadrante
no en el tercer cuadrante y eso nos
restringe a teta teta entonces está en
el intervalo menor o igual a pi medios
es decir en el primer cuadrante y menor
o igual a menos p medios es decir en el
cuarto cuadrante y ya con esto
encontramos el intervalo para el cual
está definido
y esto nos dice otra cosa más que theta
está definido en el primer cuadrante y
en el segundo cuadrante por lo tanto lo
voy a pintar del color morado para que
no olvidemos en qué parte del círculo
unitario estamos hablando y ahora lo que
voy a hacer es trabajar con esta
integral y lo que voy a hacer ahora sí
es hacer mi cambio de variable si se dan
cuenta ya tenemos que x es igual al 09
teta y ahora nos falta saber quién es la
diferencia al x y para esto lo que voy a
recordar es mi cambio de variable mi
cambio de variable decía lo siguiente x
es igual al 69 theta por lo tanto
derivamos el seno de teta que se cose no
detecta y eso lo multiplicamos por la
diferencia al de teta y ahora sí voy a
sustituir todo lo que he hecho en la
integral me va a quedar la integral de
quien me queda 1 x de x pero de x es
igual al coste no detecta diferencial de
30 por lo tanto lo voy a poner con 69
teta diferencial de teta entre la raíz
de 1 - x cuadrada pero uno menos x
cuadrada es lo mismo que uno menos el
seno cuadrado de teta haciéndome cambio
de variable y ahora para poder continuar
voy a recordar la identidad de
econométrica más importante que existe
la identidad trigonométricas más
importante que existe dice que el seno
cuadrado
en cuadrado es igual a 1 o dicho de otra
manera uno menos el seno cuadrado es
igual al coseno cuadrado y bueno todo
esto lo estoy recordando porque lo voy a
sustituir en mi integral entonces que me
va a quedar si yo pongo uno menos uno
cuadrado igual al coseno cuadrado
entonces en lugar de uno menos en un
cuadrado voy a poner el coseno cuadrado
y arriba me queda con nueve teta de teta
de abajo va a quedar la raíz de uno
menos seno cuadrado de teta pero es el
coste no cuadrado de teta y fíjense la
importancia de haber sustituido el
coseno cuadrado en lugar del 1 - seno
cuadrado de teta porque el coche no
cuadrado de teta es lo mismo que el
coche no beteta elevado al cuadrado y
entonces con esto voy a lograr que la
raíz y el cuadrado se eliminen y así me
sea más fácil simplificar por lo tanto
voy a escribir otra vez lo integral y me
va a quedar coseno de teta diferencial
de teta y si sigo usando los colores
correspondientes me queda la integral
del coche no de teta habíamos comentado
entre la raíz del costero al cuadrado de
teta pero esto simplificado me queda el
valor absoluto del coste no dt está la
raíz con el cuadrado se van y me queda
el valor
el coste de teta porque recuerden que
las raíces más menos y todo esto
diferencial de teta y ahora sí cuánto es
el coste de 90 entre el valor absoluto
del coste no detectan a bueno para esto
hay que fijarnos en donde está definido
teta y dieta está definido entre menos
pri medios y pi medios por lo tanto en
este momento cuál es el valor que toma
el coste norte está pues para esto hay
que recordar que valores toma x cuando
theta está en este intervalo y x se dan
cuenta siempre toma valores positivos
recuerden que cuando nosotros nos
fijamos en el círculo unitario x es el
valor del coste de 9 theta y entonces
como x siempre toma valores positivos
entonces el coste 9 tratamiento más
valores positivos o 0 es decir el coseno
de tetas mayor o igual que 0 y para qué
estoy haciendo todo esto porque el valor
absoluto de algo que es mayor o igual a
cero pues es ese mismo número por lo
tanto aquí en lugar de poner el valor
absoluto del cos en nueve tetas simples
esencialmente voy a poner el coste no de
tetas ya sin valor absoluto entonces me
va a quedar la integral del coche no
beteta entre el coste de teta
diferencial de teta y el coste no
detenta el coste de tal me da uno por
detectar pues me queda de teta entonces
me queda la integral de de teta que es
igual a teta más la constante de
integración pero recuerden que todavía
no hemos acabado falta hacer la
sustitución hacia atrás por lo tanto
theta era igual al largo cuyo seno se
equis entonces lo voy a poner aquí teta
es igual al largo cuyo seno se x más la
constante integración y hemos acabado ya
cuando eso obtuvimos la integral de 1
entre la raíz de 1 - x cuadrada de x o
dicho de otra manera si nosotros
derivamos algo cuyos senos x nos tiene
que dar la expresión que está dentro de
nuestra integral esta de aquí al final
estamos hablando del mismo negocio